[Music]
let's go to sarah with an h in dallas
texas what's up sarah
hi dr john how are you
i'm doing well how are you
we are having a party that's not true
we're not having a party at all we're
hanging out we're just we're working
we're working having fun so what's up
so i am little backstory um i'm 36 years
old and going on 37 this summer and
single
i've had a pretty horrible dating
experience the past few years and
have been thinking
more recently in the past year or so
about how i do
want a family and
taking the age into consideration
and
just my history
what with dating
that it could possibly be something that
i
would want to do or kind of end up doing
on my own
in terms of having a child and i've been
looking into fertility options and
potentially considering
a sperm donor and now really just
looking at all the questions that come
along with that um both for myself and
you know how do i personally deal with
that how do i deal with questions that
would come up if i do go this route and
then also
if
i did go that route and had a child what
that looks like for the child and how
how to
talk about that with a young a young kid
is it even smart to have a child without
a father so
i just have a lot of
questions and
things to come up to consider
just
i'm just going to throw i'm just going
to throw a light softball at you and see
uh good gosh this is a lot okay real
quick what what happened to your dating
thing what was so bad about that and
there's a reason why i'm asking that
question we'll circle back to it but
what happened in your in that was
terrible in your dating life
uh so i had a kind of a traumatic um
first date dating situation about eight
years ago and i've been in therapy
yeah okay yeah i'm so sorry
i'm sorry i think
yeah
so that happened eight years ago and you
were in your late 20s
and
that has rippled
through every relationship or attempted
relationship since
exactly
okay
what about before then
before then i
it wasn't as
horrible
i had i had
a handful of good dating experiences
a few
mid
long-term relationships that
that
ended they
didn't work out but it was
there was respect involved and mutual
respect and understanding just normal
dating relationships they were fine they
ended in breakups but just was what it
was right okay yeah yeah
okay so on the front end of this call
i'm gonna let you know that a i'm not an
expert here and i've got
some experience i've i had a super close
friend and she had two extraordinary
kids via sperm donor
um and so that's my that's my personal
experience here
um i do have some broader conversations
i want to have with you and i want you
to know that i'm not gonna
i am intentionally trying to walk
alongside you so if i say something the
wrong way or if i say something that
comes across like i'm against you please
hear me say that's not what i'm trying
to do okay
um all right so
that my first red flag here is how hard
it was for you to get right to the point
and say i'm thinking about having a kid
with a sperm donor
and
that the reason that's a red flag for me
is
you
you sound hurt
and anytime somebody makes a
truly life-altering forever altering
decision out of hurt it usually comes
with a
it comes with
systemic challenges both in the present
down the road
and so the first thing i think is
important for you to do
is to exhale for a minute and this is
going to be brutal and hard but you have
to grieve the picture of what you
thought your life at 37 was going to
look like
because it doesn't
and
i would get really really specific with
that grief
i thought i would have three kids by now
i thought i'd be some highfalutin lawyer
in downtown dallas and i thought i'd
married some guy who was had most of his
hair at least for crying out loud right
i think getting really specific i
thought we'd live in this neighborhood i
wanted to be here
i think really specific about that grief
because what's going to happen is you're
going to be hurting in different areas
and your
body and your brain are going to
continue to be solving for that picture
there's going to continue to be a gap
between reality and what your body's
trying to solve for
and so you're going to stuff a bunch of
stuff done in that gap potentially a new
child
or a new picture of family without fully
grieving what what isn't
and the challenge you've heard me say
this on the show a lot is the hardest
thing about new stuff
new adventures new boyfriends new
husbands new homes new kids new whatever
is that you go with you
and a new kid isn't going to
take away hurt
you hear what i'm saying
i do and i know that's hard to hear out
loud and so i'm trying to say it in the
most i'm saying it with you right like
i'm on your side of the booth here at
the bar okay
but
it's it won't fill that hole
um
what type of
what type of trauma healing have you
done over the last eight years have you
been in and out of counseling
i just started therapy
going on a year and a half ago okay
how's that going
um it's been going well
in the beginning we used the emdr
technique
and
um
i'd say probably over the past three
months i feel like i've hit a little bit
of
um
maybe like a little bit of a wall where
i
just get a sense that i'm
talking about the same things and
and coming to a point where i feel like
i'm repeating the same things and it's
are you ready to be done with that story
yeah
it's still really close
and what i mean by that is when you when
i just mentioned it a second ago your
body took off on you again didn't it
it's real close to the surface
and so that tells me for the last 18
months you've talked about it a lot
and you may have and you've done some
done some some
hacks and some you know some techniques
and emdr is incredible
but the next layer below that is a
choice too i'm not gonna carry i'm not
going to give this person any more
access to my life anymore and so i'm
going to start working at that level
and why that's hard is your body says no
we have to keep this thing top of mind
so this hurt never
happens again
and you have to go into therapy and say
okay i'm ready to be done with this
story
let's get there
tired of talking about it what are the
action steps i can take
you hear what i'm
saying yeah and that's scary as bloody
hell right
yeah and i like to have answers and i
feel like i don't know
okay how to get there yeah a
it may be time to see a new counselor
and that sucks because that means you
have to tell the whole story over again
you got to go through all this stuff
again but letting somebody who's a
world-class therapist in your community
letting them know hey here's where i've
been and i'm ready to take the next step
and be done with this and now that
you're ever going to be done with it but
i want to be able to remember what
happened and not cry and not have that
be the top of mind i want to be able to
remember what happened and not all of a
sudden
my hands are sopping wet and my heart's
racing on me i want to be able to
um tell somebody what happened because
i'm going to meet somebody i'm going to
tell that person hey this happened one
time
and or i'm going to drive through that
neighborhood and my body isn't going to
start screaming on me that's what
healing looks like nothing you forget
not that you're still not pissed off not
all that but it means that your body
goes oh no we're okay now we weren't
then but we're okay now
that's what we're aiming for
okay
so that's an aside here let's get back
to this question you asked me
um the way i see it done
and the before i mean i gotta say like
she's a close family friend and she's a
brilliant scholar and um i didn't call
her before here this this call so i i
don't want to use her name here but
here's how i saw her approach it and her
kids were incredible they played with my
kids they were awesome um she was real
open with him i mean it was as open as
open could be
like i chose you
i went to a place and i chose you
and
um
was definitely challenges with only
having one parent in the house i mean
single being a single parent is tough
and all the data will will bridge that
out and so
i think that's a separate phone call for
me and you to have some day um but yeah
it's hard being a single parent is
really hard it just is um both
financially both um emotionally but
psychologically both just having some
people in your life to help carry that
load it's hard
millions and millions people do it and
millions do it well right
um but it's hard but
man she just was pretty direct her kids
knew that um they came from a donor and
they had some info on them
here's what's happened over the last
decade is technology has improved
something dramatic
and now the conversation is people
starting to meet up on facebook groups
hey did you have donor xyz abcd one two
three four
and now the ethical issues are popping
up because
kids young people who are now grown up
to be teenagers and young adults
and even adults are able to bypass the
original um donor facility and find each
other and they're finding they have many
many many half-brothers and half sisters
and what do i do with that and do i owe
them money or am i supposed to meet with
them do they come to my family reunions
and now there's just a broader
messier much more complex situation than
a closed loop system where i had a sperm
donor nobody knows who that's in a
file folder somewhere and this is just
my new life
it just opens it up to a web a complex
web okay like with dna genetic testing
and all those kind of things
um have you thought about egg embryo
adoption
no i haven't looked uh so much into that
okay that's another just thing to think
about um couples who are going through
ivf will freeze certain number of uh
eggs fertilized eggs and then all sudden
they'll have twins and then they'll go
again they'll have twins on four kids
and there's still four or five
fertilized embryos out there and so
there's a process now where people are
beginning to adopt
fertilized images so you go through the
whole process um the challenge there is
half of it isn't yours um genetically
speaking right you still go through the
whole pregnancy process so all i have to
say is there's a there's a bunch of
options if you want to go down that road
um i would meet with somebody who's been
down that road have you talked to
somebody who's
who's been
has gotten pregnant by a donor
i haven't i have two friends that have
friends so
i'm kind of in the early stages i love
it i love it love it and the further
down the road i got i would definitely
want to talk to them about i love it
what's your what's your hang up on it
what are you nervous about
um
i think
for me it's more about the child
and
and
them going through life with questions
of you know who
you know why they were chosen like this
who their father is you know do they
ever find him do they find half brothers
and sisters those sorts of things and
and what kind of
psychological impact that would have on
i've seen a movement in the adoption
world towards more open adoptions
because there's we're getting less and
less such thing as a closed adoption
um because the technology is allowing
people to find each other so i think
down the road yes there will be the
ability for your child to find donor
father
donor dad
there will be an ability to find
half siblings all over planet earth like
those that will be built into the system
what i can't do with any sort of
integrity is speak to the i don't have
any data i don't know of any data um on
the psychological
wherewith i mean the psychological
well-being of kids who i mean we're just
on the this technology is just
relatively i mean we're just a couple
generations into this technology
and so i i don't have any data on that i
think your best bet would be to sit down
and talk with people who have
experienced it have walked through it
um what is their experience with their
kids what are the hard questions their
kids ask and by the way all kids ask
hard questions all of them do
and um there is a
i've heard about i've read a little bit
about but not enough to be
statistically sure of myself about
kids who have um been adopted have this
what they call an original heartache
that that that question that haunts them
what was so bad about me that my parents
didn't keep me and
one of the things i've heard over and
over from folks who've adopted is
they're continually having that
conversation you don't understand i
chose you right and so that's they're
they're continually closing that loop um
and some kids do great and some kids
struggle with that i think
i mean that
that's just kind of part of the deal um
that's just part of living in a screwed
up world right a hard hard world but
um
that's been my recommendation to don't
have those hard conversations i can't
answer that question for you on the
psychological state of kids and whatnot
i'm more concerned on this call with
your well-being right now
and you don't sound like you're okay
and you can tell me i'm wrong be like
dylan i'm fine i'm doing great
um i say this all the time and sarah i
hope you'll trust me
you are worth being well
and you're worth going to sleep and
you're worth thinking about your past
without your heart rate taking off on
you
and you're worth being loved recklessly
all those things and i hate
hate hate that somebody hurt you
and i hope if your dream is to become a
mom i hope that happens for you and i
hope it happens in the way that you have
a picture
of what that's going to look like and
that you're able to fulfill that picture
um and i hope you'll do the hard work of
having hard conversations with people
who are trying to become parents in
non-traditional ways
because that wisdom there is going to be
invaluable
um
will you call somebody somebody new
i will i will for you
not for me but for you
i will you promise
i promise can i tell you that you're one
of the bravest people i've talked to in
a long time
thank you and when you have a little
baby i want you to send me a photo okay
well and i also want you to reach back
out and you either email you can um
you you're supposed to slide into my dms
right i think you're supposed to do that
yeah just send me a direct message on
the internets um
but
let me know that you called somebody
some a new counselor okay
i will you will today you're so brave
thank you for being strong thank you
thank you thank you thank you